Rachel Efrat, thank you
for being on my show.
How are you?
Good. Thank you for having me.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Good morning to you. Good night to me.
You're calling from Ra'anana, right?
Yes. Yes.
Wonderful.
Okay. Rachel, I know nothing
about what are we going to talk about,
which is most exciting for me.
Because at this point, after about
a hundred and something episodes,
it's really exciting when I get to talk
to somebody and I have no idea
what they're going to tell me.
So, a little spoiler.
Today, you're a senior legal counsel
at Lightricks.
Previously, legal counsel at Gett.
But you've transition from actually,
traditional law and litigation,
into technology law.
So, Efrat, take me back,
Rachel. Sorry.
Take me back, all the way back
to when you were getting your law degree.
Do you know you're going to be in tech?
No, I had no idea.
I graduated law school.
And I immediately started
clerking for a judge.
I thought I was going to be a litigator.
In my mind, I always had this dream
of opening up my own private practice,
brick and mortar shop.
So, I clerked for a year. And then,
I worked at a plaintiff's law firm
representing people who had been
wrongfully terminated from their jobs.
Not necessarily tech. Right?
Unrelated. Completely unrelated.
Wow. So, Rachel, first of all,
litigation, paint me the picture.
What does that entail when you say
you were a litigator when you started out?
So, litigators are lawyers who go to court
and represent their clients
in legal disputes
that find their way to the courtroom.
So, as a clerk, you're the judge's
right hand man or woman.
And you prepare all of the motions,
do all of the legal research
behind the scenes, so that the Judge
can make the proper decision.
All the times that they say objection,
is that what it is?
Yes, I think you froze for a second.
Sorry, can you just repeat the last?
No. no. I was joking to ask you
if that when you say
to prepare all the motions,
that's about saying the objection.
Sure.
Like in the movies.
Okay. So, you go from litigation.
And then, where does the
your curb take you?
Sure. Sure.
So, what actually ended up happening,
I was working on a plaintiff's firm.
And then I end up moving to Israel.
I met my husband in New York,
and his work brought him back to Israel.
I came with, I thought
it would be a one year stint.
It's now been five years.
And I quickly realized
when I landed here,
that I wasn't going to do
litigation in Israel.
The whole Hebrew, I can get around.
But litigation in Hebrew
is a whole different ballgame.
Right.
So, I started realizing,
Okay. What are my opportunities here?
And a lot of the opportunities,
and you have to reinvent yourself,
which is a challenge.
Like taking a step back to move forwards.
Most of the opportunities
for English speaking American lawyers
are in tech or in the commercial space.
So, I got a job working
at a boutique law firm.
I'm representing lots of startups.
This was my first entry
into transactional work.
Because before, I had been working on,
writing motions, going to court,
depositions.
There's a lot of different things
you can do in the law.
I've been fortunate
to enjoy everything that I've done.
And I worked there for about two years.
And then, I just,
I wanted to move in-house.
It was something I thought would be fun.
You get to actually,
instead of representing lots of clients,
you have one client.
You get to know your client really well.
So, I actually, my boss at Gett,
I e-mails her.
I saw that they were looking
for legal counsel and I e-mais her.
And I told her,
"I would really love to work for you."
And one thing led to another.
I ended up getting hired there.
I worked there for three years.
Rachel, what does that mean
the legal counsel
within a company like the Gett?
And whoever doesn't know, Gett is already,
I believe, the unicorn, right?
An Israel Unicorn,
where they provide ride-sharing services
similar to Uber and Lyft across the world.
Gett is focused on different areas,
particularly also Israel.
But what does that mean
to have a legal counsel
within an organization like Gett?
Sure. So, basically what it means
as a legal counsel,
you are the in-house lawyer
for the company.
So, the company is your client.
In essence, you have one client
and that's the company.
In practice, you still have
hundreds of clients.
Because when you're
in a high growth startup,
the legal teams
tend to be relatively small.
So, you have your hands
in a lot of different places.
So, when you say you have
a hundred clients, you mean a hundred
different stakeholders within the company
who who need your assistance
under the Gett name.
But you're considering them
as a hundred different clients
because they have different needs.
Exactly. Exactly.
So, you may find yourself
working with the product team
on issues of regulatory compliance.
Like in a ride sharing company,
there's tons of regulatory needs
to make sure that your pricing
is in compliance.
You may find yourselves
working with developers
on the data team,
because GDPR, CCPA,
all of a sudden you need to get
all your data in place.
Working with the finance team
on inter-company agreements,
investment rounds,
supporting due diligence,
your Biz Dev team
on partnership agreements.
So, every single stakeholder
has totally different needs.
Actually, this is one of the things
I love about it,
because it really never gets boring.
You have insights into
so many different areas of the company.
So many different people.
And you get to see everyone's
different perspective.
But your job as legal counsel
is essentially, to advise the company.
To support them and to manage
their legal risk and exposure.
So, are you the pessimist in the group?
In the startup?
No, because I'm serious.
Because I'm thinking
of a startup organization.
Everybody's so excited about it.
It's like,
Yeah, move fast and break things.
And all of a sudden,
when I think of legal
in this context of a startup,
I think you're the downer.
The person who has to say, "No".
So, I wouldn't call it the pessimist,
but we're not always
the most popular person in the room.
Right.
So, there is a level of
having to be comfortable,
being uncomfortable.
Especially when you work in Israel
where conflict is just part of the game.
And people always just are so up front.
So, you just have to be very clear.
Know your boundaries.
I like to think that we're not the people
who are saying no.
That we're just coming
from a different perspective.
People are just, don't think the same way
that we think.
While we're also closing deals,
a lot of the time,
we're also the same people
who have to pick up the pieces
when a deal goes sour
or when litigation ensues.
Or unfortunately, sometimes,
you go through a bankruptcy event
and your legal counsel
will be involved in that.
So, we've just,
we have a different perspective.
But I like to think of it
as Problem-Solving.
And that, we look for creative solutions.
I love it. Okay.
So, I have so many questions
already lined up in my head.
But first one, at what point does a startup
need a legal counsel in-house?
Because most startups,
when I incorporated my company
in high school with my good friend Drew,
we went into Cooley and they did pro bono.
They incorporated for us.
At what point do we say,
Okay. Now we're big enough
and we're ready to have somebody
in-house to work full time with us?
I think from what I've seen, generally,
I don't know if that the CEO says,
Oh, I now I want a lawyer in-house.
But usually the board requires that
as a company matures,
after they've reached
a certain level of investment,
and things like compliance
become more important.
If you're starting to think down the road
about an exit event,
and you really need to have
all your docs in order, obviously you need
the CFO and the CFO comes, I think,
before the legal counsel.
And that's when it starts
to get more pressing.
Okay. Okay, that's fascinating.
And then, tell me a little bit about
the inside the organization
as you're sitting there.
A lot of the times you get to work
with the different stakeholders
in the organization,
whether it's at Gett or at Lightricks.
I'm assuming that a lot of the times,
the rationale that you bring to the table
in your decision making or your processes,
they're not always understood
by your colleagues, right?
And you don't necessarily
always have the time to go and explain
why you need everything
the way that you need it.
Do you find that
there's a lot of tension with that,
or, do people give you the respect of,
Okay. You know, what you're doing,
we're going to trust you?
I think, it's a work in progress.
I don't think you can expect anyone
to just listen to you because I said so.
So, everyone who you're working with,
it's a relationship.
So, that's another thing
I really like about the job.
That you have to be a people person.
So, it's relationships
that you develop over time.
You're working with a lot of different people,
but you're working with the same people
day in and day out.
So, my approach, and I'm sure,
you can speak with different lawyers.
I have different approaches,
as I try to explain to them
why I'm advising them in a certain way.
Sometimes, they really don't care
about the law.
They just want a yes or no answer.
Right.
Like, That's nice.
Just tell me if I can do it or not.
But it's also, so they can understand
the reasoning behind it.
And it's not going to be
the last question they have.
So, they can get a sense of the direction
of what's okay, what's not.
And it also helps them be prepared
for the next time.
So, they have it on their radar.
And they can actually reach out to me
if they think something is not kosher.
So, I think educating your teams,
training them,
it's helpful for everyone.
And, in the end of the day, yes,
I have an agenda as a legal counsel,
but my agenda is really
for the better of the company.
I'm not just doing it because
Rachel feels like it.
So, it's really educating the team
so that they realize
that this is important for Lightricks.
This is important for the company.
Not just because my lawyer said so.
That makes perfect sense.
And I think that,
then you are part of the organization
or a part of the culture.
And then to see with such, a lot of,
it sounds to me that almost every aspect
of the startup scene has changed
dramatically over the past 10, 15 years.
Whether it's things transitioning
from top down decisions
to bottom up decisions, responsibilities,
different ways of going about
getting a startup off the ground.
Has the legal counsel arena
within a startup changed at all
over the past 10, 15 years?
Or, is it the same methodology,
same types of people?
That I can't really say.
Because I haven't been a legal counsel
in-house for 15 years.
From your experience. Yeah.
I would imagine so.
Just because the industry has changed.
Like the technology has changed.
So, the way that things work now,
things change so quickly
because technology is changing so quickly.
And because technology
is changing so quickly,
the regulations are also changing
a bit more quickly
than they used to as well.
So, the pace is just so fast.
Especially in a high tech company.
So, I think probably the people
who want to go in-house
and be an in-house lawyer
at a tech company particularly,
need to be ready to think quickly,
have super strong intuition.
Because you will be hit with issues
that you're not an expert in everything.
But you have to know still how to react
and when you need to seek guidance
from outside counsel who are experts.
100%. I mean, one of the things
that I was just thinking about
in terms of the legal world is that,
companies have become
so much more globalized
over the past decade.
I mean, before you had the legal counsel
that were experts in the jurisdiction,
let's look at Gett, for example.
Legal experts that are
concentrated in Israel,
and transportation laws, for example.
And all of a sudden you want to branch out
because that's what every
company is doing today.
And all of a sudden
you need to have expertise
in those different countries.
It's no longer the same expertise.
You need to expand your knowledge, right?
And not just within Gett,
but every company
that is selling globally.
And today,
almost every single company
is selling globally.
Yeah, it's a huge challenge.
Because everyone wants to be global.
That's how you make money, right?
You don't make money investing in Israel.
So, it's a challenge.
Because you find yourself in a situation,
and every industry is different.
Like ride sharing, for example.
You might have different taxi laws
in New York City
compared to upstate New York.
And you're operating in the same state.
Yet the taxi rules are different.
And the pricing is different.
And all of these laws
have to be reflected in your product.
And how the price appears to the end user.
So, and then even negotiating that
across different countries
in different languages,
different tax laws,
it's a lot of work.
Because you're actually seeking guidance
from experts all over the world
in all these different jurisdictions.
And you have to decide,
Okay. Are we going to have
bespoke product
for every single jurisdiction,
or,  do we make a global solution
that will work
for every single jurisdiction?
It's a challenge.
It's definitely a challenge.
But it's exciting.
And it gives you the opportunity
to work with people all over the world
who are experts in their field,
which is amazing.
I'm very curious.
How long of an on-boarding process
is it for a legal counsel?
Traditionally, when you enter
a tech company,
I'm making a comparison as an engineer,
and having just, for example,
onboarded into Hippo Insurance,
basically within one or two days
they expect you to already be
pushing code to production.
I imagine it would be a little bit longer
for a legal counsel that has
to really get acquainted
with the company policies and legal, right?
It should.
But you're still hit the ground running.
Because usually, by the time you arrive,
they really need you.
So,  yes. You do take some time
to read your terms and conditions,
your privacy policy, meet with
all the the relevant stakeholders
to understand the different products
and road map.
But people are always pulling you
from the sides and like,
Hey, can you review this?
Hey, I have a question on this.
And you quickly understand,
Okay. These are going to be
the main issues of law
that I'm going to have
to become an expert in.
Because every industry is very different.
Right. And before I asked about,
whether your colleagues
and other employees in the organization
understand your decision making processes.
And, I'm now I'm shifting the question
more towards the leadership.
Does the leadership necessarily understand
all the legal intricacies
behind the decision making?
I'm thinking about, the CEO,
senior vice president positions,
these are people who are making
critical decisions then and there.
And I imagine that they're also the ones
who are having the most interaction
with the legal counsel
as they are considering their options.
How much do they generally understand
the legal scene
behind these different decisions?
I think that they need to understand it.
Because ultimately,
these are also the people
who are responsible for the company.
Directors and on officers.
So, even more so, it's important
for them to understand,
because if they accept risk,
they're the only ones in the company
who actually have the authority
to accept risk.
So, it's your job to explain the risks.
100% The dissidents, in my mind,
is that at the end,
you think of a startup
and a fast growing company, you think,
Okay. You want to move quickly,
you want to make decisions quickly,
and you also delegate a lot of tasks
to other decision making authorities
and you trust them.
And one of these key figures,
I'm guessing is the legal counsel.
But at the end, this is one area
in which it's imperative
that the decision makers
don't just rely on your statements,
but they have to be able
to defend them later on.
Especially since we're talking
about legal things here.
Rachel, this has been so so good to have.
Two more questions.
But first, before we end,
I want to ask you for three words
that you would best use
to describe yourself.
Okay. So, I guess I'll choose words
that are applied both personally
and professionally.
Reliable. Hardworking.
And, up for a challenge.
I love it.
And right before we leave,
Rachel, talk to me a little bit about
why you're so passionate
about what you're doing?
Coming in very fresh
into this world of legal counsel,
Why now? Why in tech?
You could have continued doing
what you were doing before.
What excites you about the work
that you're doing today?
I think it's a combination
of three facets.
I like working with people.
I like problem solving.
And especially in tech, it's never boring.
You get exposure to
the most interesting topics,
whether it's a machine learning,
privacy issues.
So, there's a cerebral part to it as well.
I love it.
Rachel, thank you very very much.
Toda raba.
Have a fantastic day.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
This is great.
You too. Thank you so much.
Bye. Take care.
Take care.